you brought you you touched on the
surface of mental health and you had
issues outside the ring and you're glad
you cured them and and i think a lot of
people listening have those same issues
but like nobody gets help
how did you like solve those problems
before because i'm in the same situation
too and like i'm i'm diving deep and
like
you know yesterday on the drive down you
had a panic attack
and uh it's just like i called my
therapist and she's like dude you you're
like so [ __ ] exposed to the roots
that like things are starting to come up
and so like you know just how did you
how did you kind of like
fix those and like because you knew
you're going to become famous yeah and
so it's like
you got to kind of put the cage around
the you know
when i was when i was younger
like
it's mad because like even when i was an
amateur i caused the big ruckus i mean
when i was an amateur when i was 16 i
put a post on cage what he was for him
um that cage while he was a big show in
the uk and the order
and the other four them on there like
the sheer dog one i mean years ago
and i put a post on the amateur forum
when i was like
four or no five on our amateur saying i
am the best amateur bands and weight in
the country does anyone dispute this
so people are putting names on this list
i was just beating them so from that
young age at like 16 when i put that up
i've started getting used to like
getting abuse you know what i mean
because like people like how these [ __ ]
this that blah blah
like this is eve like facebook was going
on so like obviously it went on today
and like i got i built a bit of a
reputation when i was an amateur i went
no no no
name
and then i went pro
when free and oprah and then got santa
cage what he is like i went out when i
was 17 because he had no one left to
fight
so i was two and a white time at him
eighteen one of the fights got sounds
cage audios
and then i was getting built up then
there's like a big thing about me first
cage where he's fighting then
i lost me next fight
obviously me ed was a bit shocked then
but it was only a kid so it was like sad
i mean i'm only 18.
went on a [ __ ] fight winston clad won
the cage audios featherweight
belt and he
started having to do proper crazy weight
cuts
145's killing me and i lose a close
fight for the belt
after that fight me i've didn't fight
for like 10 months i was
like i i soul can flip when i lose a
game of cards
only so i can always
have not prepared i've not prepared for
not put hours and hours of practice into
but when i come when if like losing a
fight affects me in a big way you know
what i mean like
so you're saying you won the belt and i
want the bells of featherweights and
then ended up losing it and that's when
i didn't know that i didn't fight for 10
months then but
like i didn't get down as bad as it did
after the next one you know what i mean
i was down
i remember
crying a lot then i'm an emotional guy
like i cry i cry commercials on the
telly okay yeah i i swear that i'll
the like i lost the featherweight belt
it was like down on the dumpster but
moving up to 30 to
moving up to lightweight
i won by flying triangle i was like oh
yeah everything's back everything's back
on you know in fact the normal
everything's back to the way it was no
need to worry anymore
and then my next fight well i broke my
hand in the lead up to that fight i
broke me for you bone and the lead up to
the civilian fight fought went to
america for four weeks train come back
can i move your mum and dad be there and
then the wedding vows and getting me
wrists look done i'm saying yeah your
hands you've got a broken bow in your
hand and they made me get surgery
before me fight so we had sadie 12 weeks
before the four for the lightweight belt
and i got the wires to help me on six
weeks before the fight the fight and
never forget it i'm taking the wires out
me and i'm sitting there going yeah i'm
fighting in six weeks and the oldest
ones
you know so
i mean i've been saying them
into shaping me foreign
so when you get away that just doesn't
add up to me 12 weeks and then you got
your wires taken out the the hardware is
supposed to be in there for a minimum of
an entire year before it comes out right
like you know what this one it was just
like why like little wires were in there
and they just like pulled the wires out
so they're keeping them maybe that's
different than hardware that's screwed
into both yeah no and then the next time
i had like i had like bolts the next
time and that was like that one again no
in the uk it was only like eight weeks
but [ __ ]
went into that fight nearly choked them
out in the first round but because my
arm was that weak i didn't i couldn't
get the squeeze on the being he could
choke no because it just didn't have to
stand the other hand did
[ __ ]
the squeeze couldn't get it next time
they hit them broke me and ended up
losing a close decision
and then after that fight that because
like even though i had the broken i'm
not gonna put everything into the build
up to it what i mean i'd say my ass off
and nothing
i just remember we went back to like the
apartment we were staying and swimming
we made to our party you know what i
mean when he'd been up anyway [ __ ]
and i just went to bed i'm just sitting
there crying
and then most i think
nearly every morning for the next six
weeks or something i woke up crying
because the messes would go to where
and when she goes away i had just
normally i'd roll over and just go
asleep you know what i mean but after
that fight that just
i'd wake up on it just like be like wow
yeah you lost that fight your kitty is
over you're finished i'm not just that
kind
but you but you fixed it yeah they are
too don't be like
for a few months that was bad for a few
months but how did you fix it i don't
know that you could fix it i think that
the like but you had better coping
skills but it was like i didn't tell
anyone
i thought oh no i'm
like
all the macho [ __ ] i'm a fighter i
shouldn't have to go to my fiance or my
mom or dad or my friends or my teammates
i shouldn't have to put this building on
them no i mean so you talked to somebody
about it so yeah for about two months i
was bad i was just crying all the time
and just never in a good mood and that's
just not me know what i mean i'm not
like that i'm always
even when i'm in a good mood i've
generally got a smile on me face
on when's the last time you lost your
fight
stuff please
okay so we're not necessarily out of the
woods no we're not right
you never know
but as you say it was it was actually
speaking to people
because
someone's seen something or someone said
to me get it off your chest that helps
i think only boxing coaches actually
right like he was the first person we
spoke to about it and then i started
speaking to other people and it was it
was weird it's literally like someone
does
pull a [ __ ] 50 key they'll wait off
your chest we're only as sick as our
secrets yeah let's leave the tip
yeah just drag it down but yeah
pretty sure yeah speaking up about stuff
that bothers you
saves my ass yeah all the time
definitely yeah you don't have to tell
you know everybody everything but you
should tell us
to sign a group the ones that you know
love you and you love them because
that's what i mean when i when i did win
that belt when i was 21 and i had maybe
death about this in the past major clean
guns people you think are friends
just with you should we call them clean
guns i mean just hanging off your coat
sales just widget to get into nightclubs
and to yeah be part of these mates you
know what i mean [ __ ] like that yeah and
at the time when you're with them your
actual mates and your fiance like what
are you doing i need me teammates in the
gym like what are you doing with them
show your [ __ ] i'm gonna call
a year passes or whatever passes and
you're like
what else they were right-wing they were
just when you lose a fight and then
you're not getting messages or
you lent someone money or you [ __ ]
don't know and you just don't want to
get back on yeah i'm just like yeah it's
sad you realize who the real ones are
and that's why i'm so happy that
happened when i was 21 when i was
younger when i won the world title on
cage
because back then i got the opportunity
when i won the belt i could just went
straight to the ufc and i would have had
all them clings on back klingons by me
side but i'm glad i never went to ufc
and i've offended the belt and then lost
it after the defender
because i wouldn't have had all the life
lessons i've got now yeah dude that's
fantastic
do you still have uh better
we're still working with better help
right
yeah that's uh yeah
therapy is crucial
um
so i mean there's just no funding for
that i know there's none in the uk and
i'm it would be surprising if there was
any foreign in the us you know what i
mean like men's mental health there's no
funding for in the uk at all there's no
phone number
funding oh yeah there's no funding at
all like no let's remember too that
patty
was it the last fight jordan levitt yeah
yeah he says i'm gonna submit him and
then i'm gonna teabag him
did you call that out ahead of time yeah
i said i was gonna knock him out or
submit him and then t-bag just said that
i'm going to finish him yeah i knew he
was going to finish him i did think more
chance of it being a knockout because he
was a better he had good jiu-jitsu
he was yeah he's a legit black belt
he's a legit black belt but
his striking defense was so weird
striking defense is just like that until
he grabs older and it was my own fault
as i said i went into the fight very
emotional was very overzealous i was
trying to take his head off with every
poncho
so because it was time to take his head
off it was easier for him to just pull
me in and get a bowl of me
and that was the same fight where five
hours before your weigh-in you received
the news that your friend you've lost
you yeah one of me
he was from
submitting jordan levitt to tea bagging
him just like he said and [ __ ]
dancing or giving like the most stellar
post-fight interview
and then just politely asking um
do you mind if i have a few words not
like grabbing the microphone like a
douche like i would
you know but two hands yeah do you mind
do you mind if i have a few words and
they just of course and then he just
goes into this like wonderful moving
speech about how we have to remove the
stigma of guys not being able to talk he
says i'd rather
uh my mate cry on my shoulder then be at
his funeral the next week like we've got
to start talking and it was just the
most [ __ ] genuine authentic
just moving this beautiful [ __ ] that you
couldn't like be trying to like put on
to look good
what kind of where do you want to see
the money go for the funding for mental
health like what what needs to be well
i'll be honest i'm no expert a lot yeah
i just know that people need help
because
even in liverpool a lot of liver the
pool fit into san diego like eight and a
half times
and i know
like more than more than ten people who
are not
not that i know directly or know of have
killed themselves over like the past 10
years yeah like it's just becoming more
and more common like it's normal and
it's not
yeah it's not normal that people need to
realize that like split second decisions
right change lives yeah you don't like
split second decision that mo unlike
things that i've seen are people who
have attempted suicide and have failed
you've always said as soon as it's hard
to do it i was thinking to myself what
the [ __ ] are you doing
i've expected it instantly well what's
crazy is like most people have these
secrets that they think is the worst
thing that's ever happened in their life
and then when you finally tell somebody
they're like i do that all the time
exactly
what do you what yeah i did that three
times last week
you know it's part of the
12 steps
they can do a fear inventory
and that's where like
you know well not even a fear inventory
but like all the harms you've done to
others
right but there's there's harm done
others there's uh you know resentments
that you have and there's a fear
inventory and so like on your fear
inventory you you have to write down
like
you know everything that you're afraid
of of course but the thing is i remember
when i was going through the process i
was thinking of like some secrets that i
had and i was like man i don't have to
share this with anybody it's not like
anything that i'm resentful about it's
not gonna make me angry you know it's
not like uh
you know it's not anything i'm really
like afraid of it's just like some weird
[ __ ] i do you know
but then i but then my next thought was
oh [ __ ] it's some weird [ __ ] i do
that
i would [ __ ] never tell anyone
because i'd be terrified of anybody
finding it out yeah and then that's when
i realized that by definition a secret
is something you're afraid someone will
find out yeah so in this process you
have to share all of your secrets and
that's when the rubber meets the road in
the 12-step process of recovery and what
i did with my secrets at that point i
[ __ ]
went to my notebook and i wrote them in
code because heaven [ __ ] forbid if
anybody got their hands on my notebook
and then they could read my [ __ ]
secrets so i wrote them in code that
only i would understand and then i told
my guy who i had to tell it to
uh i just made an appointment and um i
when when the time came i showed up and
i was like uh all right dude you know
[ __ ] that
it's like it's a big [ __ ] deal it's a
big deal it's like it's like uh what the
bull fighting guy said my guy my buddy
ty the bullfighter he says uh you're
never ready to write ride the ball it
just becomes your turn yeah
and yeah that's what it was
you know i was never gonna be ready to
share those secrets but
it became time you know i scheduled the
appointment so i go and i was like all
right here goes and and now the guy who
i'm sharing this with my you know i'll
just go ahead and say my my sponsor like
he had told me he goes look he had eight
years of sobriety at the time he had
told me he goes dude look
you can tell me anything trust me i've
been doing this for years i've heard it
all you're not gonna tell me anything
that i haven't [ __ ] heard before so
just don't even worry about it just let
it rot so i show up with my [ __ ]
coded secrets right i sit down and i
[ __ ] tell him and he sits there
listens to me when someone wants to know
what i say and he literally goes
ding ding ding that i have not heard
and we just started [ __ ] laughing and
this [ __ ] that this is this [ __ ] that
like was like so terrifying to me that i
and when i wrote it in code at the top
of the page i had written to the grave
like this was my to the grave list
yeah i wrote the words to the grave dude
and uh and here when i told my sponsor
we just started [ __ ] laughing about
how ridiculous it was and like i felt
like wow you know like
like i i had so much invested in that
festering [ __ ] fear and it was just
kind of released for sure it was
released and it was the most powerful
thing you get a lot of guys you work
with that like can't stay sober and then
like you know you go through things and
then you go to the steps and you work it
and then they relapse and you're like
would you would you not tell me yeah
all right i hooked up the dude when i
was 12 you know it's like
and it's like who cares and then like
from then on they they they
seem to hold it together
we have a book for our whole process
that which is that it's actually we call
it the big book and uh in the book it
says
if you don't if you hold back a secret
if you don't share everything you will
drink again yeah it says you'll drink
drinking like just black and white like
that and um when i got done with this
process with with the sponsor guy i
finally came to i said okay now i
finally don't have any anything else and
he says all right
uh you are the first guy i've ever
worked with in this process who i am not
now asking
so
what are you holding back
he says he says i i know that you have
not held back anything i know and he
says he says are you curious to know and
i'm like what he and he said
60.
i'm like 6 00 he goes 60 hours we put
into this process really
it was the gnarliest marathon fifth step
and i think he did a lot of rounding up
but yeah i [ __ ] and and and that's
why i think i'm still clean and sober
today because uh i like like that's when
you when you've shared your all of your
secrets when you've just like gotten it
all out that's when um
like you're no longer on defense
you know like in the steps now like you
like the the obsession to drink and use
is lifted and you're not no longer on
defense you move into the the rest of
the steps where you actually
make all the things right from your past
and now you're on offense yeah and and
like offense meaning that when you go
through the the second half of the steps
you're on [ __ ] offense now you're
playing now you're winning now your
life's getting good and dude i'm
terrified to like not to deviate from
this process
because my life is so goddamn good nice
i think that clip was awesome but not as
awesome as my new book a hard kick in
the nuts what i've learned from a
lifetime of terrible decisions which is
out september 27th and if you pre-order
it right now you can get the autographed
copy so get on it man pre-order my book
it's not going to waste your time
because i'm proven dude new york times
best seller my first book's five star
rated on amazon and i have no doubt this
one will be two so get the autographed
copy right now by pre-ordering it at
stevo.com
yeah dude